ucrania significa en ruso antiguo región
fronteriza fue dividida entre varias
potencias durante casi toda su historia
y vivió entre la influencia de polonia
al oeste y rusia al este fue parte del
imperio ruso época durante la cual
estaba prohibido hablar ucraniano base
xavier mir away store base de new crime
es un hecho importante de la historia
mundial la unión de ucrania con rusia
proclamada en enero de
1.654 hace 325 años la gran unión y su
realidad los sueños de siglos de
nuestros pueblos dulce y después de tres
años de independencia por la revolución
rusa se convirtió en una república
socialista soviética en 1922 tuvo un
papel económico importante dentro de la
unión soviética era el centro de
producción de acero carbón misiles y
tanques además de una potencia nuclear
pero en los años treinta sufrió de una
hombre una planificada por sus de stalin
para impedir cualquier movimiento
nacionalista que dejó 3,5 millones de
muertos en ocho meses
se independizó en 1991 con la caída de
la unión soviética
stuart y es por la presente pongo fin al
ejercicio de mis funciones de presidente
de la unión de repúblicas socialistas
soviéticas una pues tu presidente es
cero pero vladimir putin nunca aceptó
esta separación y llamó el fin de la
unión soviética la mayor catástrofe
geopolítica del siglo 20 en 2014 russian
yo tropas a la península de crimea este
territorio declaró su independencia y
vladimir putin su anexión
pedí que se considere un proyecto de ley
sobre la admisión de dos nuevas regiones
en rusia crimea y la ciudad de
sebastopol
actualmente rusia tiene aproximadamente
100.000 soldados desplegados en la
frontera con ucrania